[Music]
[Applause]
so this is what he does in his downtime
that's unbelievable i didn't i just
looked up there
are you dressed like santa claus on
purpose or this is just who you are
what's that that's who i am okay
security
i've got the latest uh i've got the
latest on the polling all right
presidential candidates yeah new polling
ladies and gentlemen shows president
obama has a 10-point lead in mitt
romney's home state of michigan
[Applause]
although
although in obama's home state of hawaii
romney has a 10 house lead
that's a lot of property how we doing
santa we're all right now
okay i just lost my choo choo train
[Laughter]
what else is going on you all heard this
is the big story today mcdonald's
announced they're going to start posting
for the first time ever the calorie
count of their menu items
yeah
yeah not to be outdone cinnabon
announced they will start posting their
death toll
[Applause]
no just
just like mcdonald's says you know
billions served
millions dead yeah
[Applause]
they don't they're our sponsors oh the
producer says yes they're sponsored
there are sponsors on the show why would
you let a joke like that go through
what the hell are you doing
what that's cash out of our pockets
cinnabon
you're the best yeah we what we mean to
say is they died happy
[Music]
good day thank you
we're back in the cache richter thank
you
i couldn't believe this yesterday the
dalai lama said it's time for humanity
to abandon religion
that's what he said yeah
man
sounds like someone just got dumped
what
no more religion
he's despondent uh what else is going on
coca-cola this is fascinating coca-cola
is now sold
in 193
of 195 of the world's countries can you
believe that yeah yeah the holdouts are
cuba and the former soviet republic of
caffeine-free seven upstand
[Music]
interesting story at a high school in
texas a science experiment backfired and
the school was evacuated
now
the experiment that backfired was trying
to teach science in texas
i'm killing with santa
you're gonna like this one
kringle uh
[Laughter]
hooters restaurants are making
contact huh
i talk about the election
[Music]
hooters what
speak up there conan
hooters restaurants are making an effort
to bring in more female customers
they want to get more female customers
yeah hooters said the only things they
need to change the name the waitresses
and the food other than that they're
fine
this is interesting i don't know if you
watched the newsroom on hbo but one of
the stars of the newsroom accidentally
tweeted a topless photo
yeah
unfortunately it was jeff daniels
[Applause]
and then uh i've got to mention this
and santa's not gonna like this one
oh man
well the premise is good yeah you'll
like this according to new research
heavier men last longer in bed
yeah
but that includes time spent looking for
their penis
[Applause]
[Applause]